okay I think we get status
the second
yeah
Stanford University and the title is
local algorithms for
predicting everybody
thanks for the introduction and thanks
for having me here my name is
and I'm a PhD student at Stanford
University advised by Emily summary and
today I'm excited to talk about our very
recent work about algorithms and
epidemics
so most of the infection is spread from
some kind of person-to-person contacts
and networks emerge naturally in the
study of epidemics but how does this
network look like will change how does
the infection behave throughout the
network for example if I have isolated
clicks of households and one of them
randomly get infected from traveling the
risks are safe but if on the other half
I have like a particular household and
they travel and get covered all of the
town are in some sort of risk
so properties of the network are
important but at the same time we cannot
map the whole network so the main
question we're asking is what kind of
information about the network do we need
to predict the epidemics and I'd be more
precise about the question but let me
first uh Define what's the epidemic
model or network that we have
so we are considering an sir model which
is a very relevant model for infection
that bring immunity to the recovered
people
each node or each individual can have
either of the three states susceptible
infectiously recovery and when I know
you get infected there are infectious
for a Time T this could be random and
why they're infected they can transmit
the disease to their susceptible known
at some rate better so for example this
first node is infected and they can
transmit the disease to their neighbor
and then their neighbor can translate
this to another node and then all of
them recover before infecting more
people
and for how long the time that a node is
infectious we can have different choices
for example T could be a constant or it
could be random for example drawn from
exponential random variable and that
depends on how we want to work
model the epidemics but for now let's
just keep it as simple as well is there
any question about the model
okay
so now that we know the model let's go
to a thought experiment let's say we
have two copies of the same city and I'm
looking at it at day one of an infection
I know exactly which people are infected
in both of them it's the same set of
people
but from now on the infection is going
to be spread independently in these two
parallel words and because of the
randomness of the infection how people
are what sort of people are getting
infection are going to be different
so we can ask different questions here
like in these two set of cities even if
I have the network can I say what's the
probability that an outbreak happens or
can I say if an outbreak happens what's
the size of it or what's the time
evolution of these three different
components sir so now I'm going to run
the simulation both networks and you see
as it grows while the initial condition
was the same this different set of
people are getting infected at time and
even at the end like the cranials are
the ones that have getting recovered you
see like for example this set of people
didn't get infected but there they got
infected
but it seems like the time Evolution
look kind of the same can I say that is
true theoretically or not
so to answer these kind of questions
about epidemics and network the
traditional approach is a network model
kind of approach what do I mean by that
there are two steps I have to make here
first I have to choose a random Network
model to see how the interaction between
people go and I have many choices for
that I could have started with like
erdog traini where there's a homogeneous
mixing of people any two person can have
the same sort of probability of getting
connected or I could say oh that's not
realistic I can introduce super
spreaders to the network by looking at
configuration model for example or there
are also modelers to like look at the
Dynamics of network where people come
and get friends with more popular people
or it could be that like I have some
data about uh demographics of people and
based on that I can see what's the risk
of getting infected and for that there
are like stochastic black mother too
uh capture those kind of Dynamics and in
all of these models there's a problem
that I don't have any Loops when I look
at the network so there are models who
capture that for example the household
model to get to add like Loops or low
color structures to the graph I'm just
saying this long lists to say that like
there are many choices to make in this
first step to just model the interaction
between people and it's not really
obvious which of these is the right one
and even after I make that decision
there is a second step that I have to
estimate the relevant model parameters
after that why don't what do I mean by
that so let's say I want to for example
predict the size of an outbreak and I've
chosen Elder training class and I have
to estimate the average degree or if I
have chosen the configuration model I
have to estimate the degree sequence to
say something about the outbreak size
and each of these two steps I can make
mistakes and it's not really obvious how
much my mistake would change the my
prediction or not
the main question you're asking here is
that can we have a model free estimation
of epidemics for example predicting
probability size of an outbreak or all
this time Evolution Without Really
assuming the net worth model foreign
I'm going to say that under some
condition this is true only local
information about the network is enough
to get the whole time evolution of the
sir process
and you don't need to know the network
model so we are assuming the first Sil
process that I told you and I assume
that initially each person have the same
chance of getting infected with some
property Alpha this could be very small
but for many General graphs I can
evaluate the time evolution of Sir by
only looking at local structures
so next I'm going to Define what do I
mean by evaluating the local structure
so I'm going to Define an algorithm that
looks at least local
Network structure to predict a type
Revolution
so what's this algorithm let's say
I have this whole big Network I don't
have access to it but I'm going to probe
the networking some information about
the network by some sort of contact
tracing in a way so I in this algorithm
I draw a uniform random node
and I'm going to see for example at time
T let's say a week from now what's the
number of people in sir
and the algorithm draws a uniform random
note and look at this K neighborhood and
runs the infection on that chain
neighborhood and then return the status
of V at time T for example with big
thumbnail
so I said initially each note has the
same chance of getting infected in one
example of the run of the algorithm to
take out first
uh we see like for example one node is
infected initially and then it starts
yeah
it's like I do the best depth first
process until I get to K notes
um but it's not I will tell you it's not
that important like how do you define
the candidate
is
something so we ordered the status of
everyone
after I get like Decay other notes in
that neighborhood and then one note of
infected I run the infection after time
T and in this run we didn't get infected
so I set the status of V at the end is s
so that's what the difference is
make few different questions
one of the three sir possibilities so
that you have
and then one sort of estimator is that I
take average of like what fraction of
loser myself as the S was fraction was
in I blood pressure was an r and that's
the instrument
basically so it's I guess very simple
way of estimating Sir with only local
information
so this is like for the case that I want
to see a finite time T but what what I
want to see for example what happens at
the end of the epidemic what's the size
of an infection
then I could change the algorithm really
difficult I could say oh like Iran after
10 T Infinity but that might be a bit
costly but at the same time I could say
um let's say if I had the network and I
pick a random note what's the chance
that that random node is going to be
impacted at the end of the day so
instead of running the infection forward
I can think of reversing the time and
see assuming that if they first know
that I picked randomly was infected who
has infected it and who has infected
their infected never until I see if that
is growing or not
so following that idea
I start with the uniform random node
and I see that like in my draw this note
was wasn't initially infected so I see
if assuming this node is getting
infected who is going to infect this
noise
and I contact trace it in a way
and their neighbor wasn't a student
initially okay so I should see if it's
getting to someone who is getting
infected initially or not and well yeah
I get to somewhere here so in this
scenario of K24 my algorithm returns
true that like my drawn uniform random
node is getting infected locally
let's say I don't I contact resident to
like level four after getting to four
people and I don't get too initial
infected person in that case it just
returns zero
so these are the very simple estimators
for
locally estimating the size of an
outbreak at the time evolution of an
outfit and very recently with Christian
Amin and Remco we showed that these are
actually all the right explanatory
for so for a sequence of convergent
graphs I will Define that later what
does that mean just get it from me that
like most of the network model that you
can imagine satisfy that condition
a constant number of queries with a
constant K is enough
to get the final size of an infection
from the last estimator that I showed
you
and also from the first estimator with
the constant number of query and
constant K I can get the time evolution
of sir
these are assuming that initially Alpha
fraction of people getting infected but
they can also take that Alpha to zero
and it's still these estimators are the
right thing to look at
a few notes about the algorithm first of
all the way that I'll show you it may be
it's not very immediate to see it but it
can be implemented in of what even the
first algorithm I could
uh implement it off one even if I have a
few nodes of a large video notes I could
just do it back for in a sense and it's
model 3 of course I didn't ask you
anything about the method and it
preserves age differential privacy so if
I care about not revealing information
of edges that's fine
and it's extendable to Dynamic networks
that nodes can come or removed from the
network from something
and it doesn't require anything like low
calorie like a structure which is in
implicitly assumed in many of the
network model
there is a setting this kind of model
so if there is no question I want to now
change the initial and condition
so far I've been assuming that like
Alpha fraction of people are infected
initially but let's say
it's very early stages of Kobe and I
want to see what happens if one person
has traveled from another country to the
U.S how would the infection go and
that's a very different kind of question
because when only a few people are
infected initially there is a whole
sarcasity going on in the beginning that
I cannot really predict it and it's not
just that like as you can see in this
simulation even after the beginning
um there is a whole Randomness in how
the Eye Care looks for example
these two graphs
so maybe I cannot wish for
um constructing these whole sir curves
for General gaps but maybe I can assume
something about the graph
which is not the network model but some
go over structured that can promise me
local
algorithms are enough for estimating
hours for exercise for example
so another example why local structures
aren't enough because I can construct
two different sort of graphs that have
the same local structure but different
artwork size so on the right I have a
four regular grind on graph on size n
and on the left I have four regular
random graphs as a smaller size and
locally they look like the same but if I
one person here get infected many other
are getting infected and one person
getting infected they're only logging
people are getting infected so I can't
even say anything about the artificial
let alone the whole sir process
in these two graphs
so here
we assume that the network if they
assume if the network is well connected
enough
and if I simplify the random process of
the infection a little bit I can still
estimate the relative size and the
probability of an outbreak with local
samples
so here I'm assuming a single epidemic
wire meaning that the recovery time is a
constant it's not random as it was
before
and I'm defining the outbreak as the
event that Omega and number Super
constant number of people getting
infected
and then we said that
the probability that this event happened
and the size of an hour's break as a
result of it is a local has a local
structure
well so far I haven't give you an
estimating for a probability of an
outbreak because before Alpha fraction
was already infected so what would be a
natural estimator for the probability of
an outbreak
still I have this whole network that I
don't have access to it and still I want
to draw one uniform random node and look
at local structure but instead now I
assume we is the first person and see if
that person is going to infect many
people or as as I want or not so locally
with k equal to four I started infection
from V and I see that it doesn't lead to
four infecting for other people so in
this run of the simulation I say I
return zero but if V could infect four
other people I would return one and say
of these like probably leading to enough
right
and then as a natural estimator again I
can make a few queries of this algorithm
and take average over the result foreign
so far I have told you an estimator for
the time Evolution for the outbreak size
and outbreak probability but it turns
out that if under the conditions that we
have under the infection model that we
have the probability and the size of the
outbreak are the same on well-connected
Networks
so with Christian and I mainly prove
that if we have a sequence of well
connected graphs and I will Define that
more formally later
then the final size of an infection is a
two atom random virus
so the relative size of an infection
converges to a random fiber that's
either zero or some constant of P where
p is a transmission right
and we see that this random variable the
constant P appears with the same
probabilities at a p so that's not
random that says that the infection
relative size is the same as the
probability of an outbreak that happens
here
so the big takeaways of this is that the
infection the final infection size the
high probability is either constant or
Zeta P times n
and the probability on the size are the
same with constant recovery time of
Desire
so now that we know this information the
second part of the result is that there
is estimated as I showed you about the
probability is actually the right
estimator to approximate given about my
approximation of the relative size and
the probability of an outbreak
so if there's no question
um could you say something about how
large these constants are and as a
function of the parameters that's a
great question I can say something about
how human can be nice that just coming
from some general form so it goes I
guess relatively fine with Epsilon but
how K or like this
Epsilon depends on the graph needs which
um so you can you can just drag around
the simulation and see when does it
convert but I don't have a convergence
results
I will show you some simulation results
with respect to that transmission
process too yeah if you can change the
transmission process as long as it has
some more conditions
which makes infections independent isn't
it
I mean the independence between the
infection
transmission
sound throughout the duration
if there's no question about the result
I go through why what what are the
conditions
which is is better changes this time uh
it cannot lose it yeah but it's better
would be different or different edges
foreign
limit if the distribution of a typical
note of a uniform random node
converges so what do I mean by that in
an example in a simple example let's say
I have this kind of grid and I'm growing
the size and I have two kinds of notes
here either the green ones or the blue
ones and if you look at the green nodes
all of them have degree A's and their
neighbors have degree four the neighbor
of neighbor have W8 again so if you look
at them locally they all look the same
and if you look at the Blue Notes they
all look the same so a uniform random
node with probably half is green because
it has this blue to this sort of graph
it's like having a limit but this is a
very simple example of crafts with limit
and we see a lot of many more examples
in the boot camp including a few of them
that are very relevant Network model for
example editors training and
configuration model that have a
branching process limit preferential
attachments or household models you can
Define I guess any kind of network any
kind of
um easy Network model have like some
sort of limit in a sense
so getting to the second condition which
was well connectedness or expansion
so a graph is an expander if you want to
remove a set of nodes s from the rest of
the graph then you have to remove
linearly as many edges
to disconnect it in some sense
and we actually need a weaker condition
of this sort of expansion meaning that I
only need to have that condition and a
set of sizes that have linear size in it
so I could have potentially a few
disconnected components but as long as
sets of linear sizes and N are well
connected to the rest of the town then
it's fine
so I guess any any single time that you
so for example Berkeley is expander I
guess but maybe if you look at the union
of Berkeley
and I don't know Cornell maybe it's not
so examples of a few convergent large
with expander meaning that a few graphs
are satisfy all of our condition for our
second result our configuration model
prefercial attachment models and
household models and I've said the
household models a bunch of time so tell
you what what is it like in a high level
you can start with any sort of graph
that you want
and then you can blow up the vertices
with any local structure that you want
as long as it's connected and the size
is bounded then you're fine so that's
like you're introducing households
instead of like that we know you're
introducing a household of three people
so if this kind of network model allows
you to introduce any local structure
that you want and as long as the
external graph has the conditions that
we need like expansion and convergence
then after you blow it up it's still
like it has the condition that we need
so you can apply our local algorithm to
get outbreak size on them as well
so before getting you to some proof
ideas let me show you some simulation
and real data so here we are looking at
Copenhagen data set which is
um which was a data set for
flu epidemics in 2019 they tracked
students GPS data
and it has like around 100 nodes and we
put edges if these sets are within six
periods within like half an hour or so
and here I'm actually answering the
question the Suraj of how large would be
cake so I was really like how large
should we care to for example estimate
the probability of an outbreak when I
started with k equal to 0 or almost
exactly always like the first one is
infected so I'm overestimating by far
it's like probably one but as I increase
K when I get to 3 then it's almost very
close to the real probability of an
outbreak
so you don't really need to like grow
the decade
a lot High compared to the whole network
size
so if there are no question I get to
some high level proof ideas about the
last part of the results
yes they actually are not sure what what
does care really mean
okay it's like the infection for other
people okay that's all four
neighborhoods but that's because that's
a production number of your simulation
so no it's not the reproduction so here
like the transmission rate is
almost yeah
um this K depends is kind of saying how
much knowing the local stroke how far
going deep into the grass is enough or
not so if you want to for example if I
had let's say in a context for example I
had access to uniform random samples and
I only like contacted when I when I see
an infected mode contact person up to
like four people that's enough for me to
say something about what would be the
side of the planet
it goes out okay equals four doesn't
mean I've impacted poor people no
eventually yeah Generations
very good
I haven't read the question so here you
show how
the approximation behaves with respect
to K
P to 5K like if you have data
not yet but I would just like run the
impatient receiver does it coverage but
that's a great question from the study
letters to see what would happen
any other questions
so if I think of these as sub graphs
around that node B that you're picking
these are all three sub graphs no or
they're Chains No they could be anything
actually that's the point of a result
but but you're not seeing how for
example so if if V connects to X and Y
you're not looking you're not looking at
x to y or you're also looking at yeah
yeah I made my uh yeah I'm looking at
that too you're looking and and that is
counted as part of a query or no that's
not counted so bigquery doesn't return
to me the whole structure it just tells
me whether it reached to pay other
people and it doesn't matter if it goes
through a loop or not right but doesn't
that count as a budget if you have to
then in in a way you are querying
whether X had contact with y
um
I'm not sure
well we should talk afterwards but but
what you're telling me is that if I pick
a v
and I'm doing this querying I I don't
necessarily get a tree I can actually
get something that's more expressive
than a tree yeah so like that this whole
algorithm is a black box for me if it
doesn't get a tree or not doesn't matter
it doesn't tell what what it gets it
just tells me eventually getting
so yeah so it could be the triangle
starts from V gets to x and x gets to Y
where it would be Y is already like
getting
um
we can talk later
Red Line seems to be around 0.18 or
something yes is my interpretation
correct that that is give you for this
given data
Express
let me say was it a big outbreak or not
you repeat this 10 000 times
yes that's the exact
ly that's a truth
how did you find big was a bigger than
five percent so what was your definition
what's the outbreak size yeah it can be
kind of fine as five percent but I guess
I guess so it's male connected enough so
that if it gets to five percent gets to
it's always like this final size of
asparagus but
there's one more question
confidence but why does it
down the the bigger case so here the
confidence interval depends on the
number of where it's not changed I fixed
the number of queries I've always
query 10 times
like I'm always contact tracing text
following some sense if I increase Q
then I never done it
it's a good question
and this is a scenario where there's no
intervention whatsoever going on yeah
so there are no more questions I can get
to some high level ideas
so when we have Sr with constant
recovery time it connects to some very
well-known notion for mathematicians and
subsets which is called pre-collection
in percolation I keep each edge with the
same fixed probability p and I call that
g of P
and we want to show that it's like oh
with constant recovery time can be
coupled to this kind of percolation so
instead of looking at algebraic size in
a dynamic inflection process I can look
at the largest component or the Giant in
this corresponding gfp
so the next goal is to see what would be
the size of the giant in grp which I'll
show you in a slide
so we showed that under the same
sequence of paths like we are connected
converging graphs the sergeant of the
largest component Over N always
converges to a fixed number which is
actually the size of the outbreak in our
epidemic notion
and the second largest component always
converges to zero
so what we showed is that the largest
component is unique the size convergence
and in some sense also we can estimate
the
thresholds where where we have like a
large component or not
so how can we show the size of the
largest component converges
pictorially yeah
very high level I can bound the relative
number of nodes in the largest component
with two values that I can easily say
those two values converge so the upper
one is actually
kind of easy so instead of looking at
the relative number of nodes in the
largest component I look at the nodes
that appear in the component of larger
than K this K is actually the same K of
contact Tracy I was telling you so
everything that appears there actually
is in a large component as well so
that's the upper one
and as a lower Bond instead of looking
at gfp I lower the transmission rate
with some Epsilon if you have Epsilon
and then I look at the nodes that appear
in the component larger than K in this
new graph
and this lower one is actually the hard
part to prove which we use a very well
known technique of sprinkling here
if I show like these two bounds are the
right bonds then I can show that
this quantities the upper body and the
lower Bond are both local so like they
only depend on this case structure they
both converge and then I need to show
that
um this Delta K like this P minus
Epsilon quantity then the P quantity are
very close so I need to sum
how should I have like there is this
data is a
continuous function of p in the sense of
an epidemic that means that if I let's
say I didn't know this true probability
of p and I was estimating it and I had
some error but that's fine because this
outbreak size or our probability is a
continuous function of that piece so if
I have like a good estimate of that
that's still fine with me
and uh
so now maybe for for a few minutes I
tell I get into more detail of like how
does this sprinkling looks like here
this is actually as I said is a has a
very long history going back to Erdos
and many more people have used it that I
haven't listed here
and the idea is basically that
I start I was looking at this infection
process with transmission red P but
instead I lowered it as I said so I have
this original graph I have the graph
with probability P1 P1 is less than my
original infection rate and I add back
that property Epsilon to it such that if
I look at the union of GN of P1 and Gene
of Epsilon the probability that hap
years is the same as the probability NH
appears in G of P so the same
transmission rate
and I want to say that any sort of
component of size K here will attach
together with these orange edges to
create a large component here
so that's the basic idea
and um
if I want to get to more detail at the
Second Step I have to show that there
are linear number of nodes that appear
of component size larger than k
and then I have to say that if I look at
the unions of components of size
argument K like if I can separate them
in two sets of A and B the probability
that they are not connected is actually
very low they are not connected in this
like orange graph
and then if I say all of these steps I
can say that I have like a large
component of linear size
so I can get into more detail of this
like step two but I
um I just go very fast I guess
um the idea like the very combinatorial
idea he's here coming from some main
some material called mango theorem it
says that if I have a well-connected
network and I look at two large sets of
size of of A and B and um I know if I
want to disconnect A and B I have to
remove many edges this toron says that
because of that there are many HD
showing paths between them so like what
do I mean by age district for example
the green pact blue and the red the
orange don't have any Edge in common and
why do I care about that because if I
add them back with probability
absolutely I don't I want those to be
independent in some way so this kind of
theorem allows me to like say that if I
have these two sets of large A and B in
my original P minus Epsilon graph after
I add back edges with probability
Epsilon with high probability one of
these paths is going to actually appear
and I can then take the union bonds over
all of these sets and say that there is
no way to Partition
so these are getting very
but I guess going back to the main
takeaway of the talk
local information goes a long way so if
you want to predict some Global property
like probability of an outbreak or the
size of it you can only look at these
local structure of the graph especially
if Alpha fraction is infected you don't
need to really assume anything about the
network structure except this conversion
condition and if you if you start with
one note then it's more complicated and
we need some sort of expansion or some
sort of very connectedness to say
something about the outbreak size
and uh all of this has been enabled for
us because of grappling this can we find
more application of this graph units or
not
and with that thank you and I'll be
happy to get one
question so in uh like property testing
uh
often it starts with one graph model you
know like an Instagram model and it's
you know Community fixed degree and then
people go and figure results about
General graphs I mean depending on what
the question is so I mean uh does this
mean sort of more generally as an
approach where you can say forget about
modeling what the graph looks like maybe
we can solve problems and find out maybe
what the graph looks like and then adopt
I mean you're not finding out like
you're just asking specific questions
about specific nodes whereas I guess in
properties and you want to know about
some property of the whole graph
uh so you want to know about a global
property the local information but
usually
the graph is a particular
this is my question so I guess
um I just repeat the question for every
child yeah I can just say so all I'm
saying is
thinking about property testing where
often you are so you want to know a
global property but you want to do find
it out with local information but almost
in all the results I know about which
is when I was doing this was a while ago
is that you assume one graph model maybe
it's a dense graph then it's the
constant degree then maybe
um other models and hopefully eventually
it's for General graphs uh so your
approach seems to say at least for local
answers not for Global answers that
maybe you could just uh sort of search
what the graph looks like and then adopt
and one approach or another
I was just wondering if that's something
people do maybe they do I don't know
that's a great question I don't I don't
know I haven't looked into it uh to see
what's answered but uh I guess it has a
potential to like look at these local
structure and say something about the
global property after that I guess
that's a very great question to look
are there any more questions we have
plenty of time
okay
so I talked about two regimes of having
Alpha fraction or one any comments or
anything in this game
in terms of initial I guess in between
condition is when uh Alpha goes to zero
and so like
we still have our results still that
close so when also goes to zero this is
the first result
what is the rate or does it matter
um no it doesn't matter if yeah
so I guess if it doesn't depend on N
it's fine
I should give you the microphone so
people online
that's okay noise I need the exercise
um so I guess I was wondering if we had
a really big graph is there some sort of
way that we could get a sense of whether
it's well described as a graph limit and
we could try to apply these things to it
that that's a great question I guess uh
maybe Christian has a comment on it but
I think there's so the question is that
if we just have a fixed car can we say
it's well described as a graph limit or
not
and I think we don't know theoretically
if we can describe just to fix graph as
a craft limit or not
but I guess morally
these kind of
um methods apply to it as a learning
that's like local structures of random
nodes I have
have some sort of failure distribution
so you had a slide where the sort of the
theorem would state that I don't know
networks and graph is well as you guys
do but it was a sequence of large set
expanders with bounded average degree
converging locally in probability so
that I guess that somehow formulates
what is necessary for the network to
have sort of some
stability as you send but for people
like me is it possible to explain sort
of in I guess it means that as you look
at the larger larger Network
with picking around them local structure
it should sort of stabilize as n tends
to Infinity is that more or less what it
means the convergence part is more or
less what that means exactly so like I
need to be that the typical node is
because the structure has like some
distribution so if I look at the
empirical distribution of local
structures though that's like conversion
yeah and then about the expansion part
that's like just
um ensuring that like I don't have two
disconnected community in some sense and
it's still like many of these random
graph model like configuration model
preferential attachment and how someone
will have that problem I think
the result you have
has already been proven for those three
examples but I guess your situation is
much more General exactly so the
interesting thing is when you go outside
of those modes because right I think the
results already existed for those three
models and many others but you have a
more General situation yes exactly thank
you foreign
let's choose like QE your query number
of groups I am the government I pay them
to give them to give me all the
information and test regularly and as
long as I monitor those asphalts call
them or groups I can have good estimates
about the work or like my country but
you also to pay them for Quality to get
it
I see what you're saying so I have to
initiate the infection too if I if I
have the transmission rate I can
simulate the infection but yes I guess
that's that thank you very much
exercise
excellent talk
um so I know that you don't know
um the leading eigenvalue of The
adjacency Matrix but what is the
relationship between K and that leading
eigenvalue of The adjacency Matrix
I haven't looked at
it
related yeah
because the leading
um eigenvalue of the agency Matrix
tells you about many different ways
same with are not the spectral radius of
the Next Generation
another question Joe
I can ask a question
okay let me ask a question quickly uh
so my understanding is you're saying
okay
in this situation with just local
information is all we need to
characterize and to be able to
realistically estimate the final size of
an epidemic but suppose I'm looking at
it from the point of view of let's say
we have a meta population model or the
total population is split into multiple
patches and the patches are connected by
by Mobility so if I'm in patch a
and so to characterize what's happening
in my parts I just need to focus on my
Patcher not any of the connected patches
but sometimes what's happening in other
purchases non-trivial consequence is
what's likely to happen in our patch so
how do you extend or how do you what do
you can you speculate if you have a meta
population structure but we still need
just the local information or we also
need
what's happening for example in one
patch maybe a lot of people are
vaccinated or if I've been quarantined
but another patch is not uh what's the
impact of that kind of structure meta
population part structure the results
that you have
six
it's a goodbye can you still say that
metal population structure
has some sort of limited distribution
on the side of the draft and still I can
say something with this local
information but if they are very
heterogeneous I don't know if like one
patch is all vaccinated and the other is
not then maybe I should study them
separately like
like people coming in like the the US
from many different countries
so we focus more on what's Happening
Here
but not necessarily
um
that will not affect the final size of
the activities just the final determined
by What's Happening Here rather than how
many people are coming in from other
parties or other countries whether it's
a large number of infections in those
countries or not but they can affect
their photos size here too because of
this transportation and
so like saying about what our local
result can do as long as I have samples
from both both attachments I can say
something okay good to know any other
question we have 10 minutes so I have
plenty of time to ask husband because
this is so exciting talk I like
the one
we can do that yeah but that's against
the law to enter
no it's so exciting it's very nice but
if there are no questions then let there
I think oh sorry that's a question yeah
you think about it
so you had a fixed infection spirit and
if you have a random infection Spirit
then of course the
possibility of infection your friends
will be become dependent
did you so what do you mean by your
brand well if I have four friends and if
my infectious pair is random then the
probability that I in fact uh let's say
you and Christian will become dependent
because if I have a long infectious
period it's more likely that are
infected but you said you that's exactly
the first setup so if I assume that like
uh
initially if I assume something about
the initial condition then here this is
assuming the General Sir uh it's not a
constant coverage it's a random recovery
time then I can say it is local
information right now but when you
started with one person you excluded
that case so my question is
if you want to include it what was the
problem that
sort of Why Did You exclude that what
was the Are you seriously why we looked
at the simpler I mean I always do that
if I can't solve a problem which happens
most of the time then I go to simpler
situation I always do that so I but what
was the complicating Factor let's say I
guess when
um that's a great question I guess the
the when we'd have this independency we
can look at the pre-collection we can
um we can think of infection as an
undirected uh network instead of looking
at all the transmission because of
symmetry and that makes this study a lot
easier and we couldn't yet that's our
first like that's that's our next goal
to see what would happen if we have
these uh the actual sir model with like
coupling on the expanders and one effect
on what would happen but yeah we don't
know yet
so when we're working on that obviously
we first wanted to do what you said
um with this I mean you're going to
discover two problems
um one of them if the graph is locally
tree-like we didn't quite know how to
prove it in this General ISD anyhow but
there one might have some hope
um it's still difficult but the main
problem is actually if it's not locally
tree-like Zen actually it's very hard to
understand this process because once you
start to get sort of two ways to a node
and even if you're conditioned I mean
that you lose all kinds of Independence
which make it very hard to analyze
much more complicated
the last one probably so the sir is it
uh epidemic sir or endemic sir is it for
like a brand new disease or you do not
include the demographics
but this process or is it for today that
has been endemic has established itself
so in which case now you have this
inflow of new susceptible people into
because if it's epidemic
then the disease will run out eventually
of horse to infect right because you
don't have any influx of I guess the way
that you're defining epidemic and
endemic it's probably epidemic because
I'm looking at the fixed static Network
that the disease will eventually run out
oh okay sorry okay excellent right next
all right let's think yeah you know one
more time for fantastic fantastic
foreign